[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité dimanche 17
septembre la ville de Trappes le Djamel
Comedy Club et le Secours populaire
s'unissent pour un gala caritatif en
soutien au sinistré du tremblement de
terre survenu au Maroc 6 humoristes du
Jamel Comedy Club se succède rond sur la
scène de la mairie la totalité des
recettes sera versée au Secours
populaire pour financer ses actions au
Maroc mardi 12 septembre la Fondation
Orange a remis des diplômes à des femmes
yvelinoises isolées de l'emploi
accompagnée par le Centre d'Information
sur les Droits des femmes et des
familles des Yvelines elles étaient une
vingtaine à avoir suivi des cours sur
des outils numériques dispensés par la
Fondation Orange je suis contente parce
que je connaissais rien dans
l'ordinateur et du coup ça m'a permis
d'être à l'aise et puis c'était un
groupe sympathique quand on venait il y
avait pas de comment je peux dire on se
sentait pas sous-estimé et deux sessions
ça a duré sur un an et beaucoup ne sont
pas là aujourd'hui parce qu'elles sont
par exemple en poste toujours du côté de
l'emploi le centre commercial one nation
Paris et ses magasins recherchent de
nouveaux profils pour renforcer leurs
équipes plus de 50 postes sont à
pourvoir un job dating se tiendra dans
le centre je dis 14 septembre de 14h à
19h il était important pour nous de
faire ce recrutement déjà pour pouvoir
favoriser le recrutement pour nos
boutiques ça prend beaucoup de temps et
donc nous avons de nouvelles enseignes
nous avons les renforts de fin d'année
plus des événements que nous allons
vivre sur la fin d'année qui nous
demande de renforcer les équipes en
magasin